some high-octane GP battle racing with
Mario characters how can I not do a
video on this I mean Mario Kart 7
alright so by now I'm pretty sure you
guys are familiar with the Mario Kart
setup if not here you go Mario Kart is
go kart battle racing with Mario
characters you can get items and use
them against guys and wipe them out so
you can get ahead in Mario Kart that
being said now we have Mario Kart for
the 3ds and it's just like Mario Kart
only a little more fun and this is why
okay in the previous Mario Kart games it
felt like it was you versus the world
you were Scott Pilgrim and you reversing
the world by world I mean seven other
guys when he did the GP racing it felt
like everyone was like all right yeah
let's target the player alright guys
let's do this remember you'd play mario
kart mario kart for the DES or something
you see a player a couple people behind
you and he would get a red shell and he
would wait and tell he was right behind
you to throw that red shell right up
your ass and this one he'll throw it at
the other characters behind you before
he actually gets to you that is polite
that's awesome that's sportsmanship and
Mario Kart 7 it feels like everyone is
fighting everyone to get into first
place not just you so that's awesome
I mean a couple of times I got hit by a
lightning bolt just as I was jumping off
of a ramp so it was like pair oh well
that sucks
so yeah they're not above screwing you
over but they will screw over other
characters to take solace in that so in
the GP mode you have 50cc 100cc and 150
CC now 50cc 100cc you smoke through
you're like alright these guys are
nothing it's you don't unlock anything
for it either it's practice it's the
calm before the storm because then you
get to a hundred and fifty CC and then
everyone just sucks these little
bastards are cold and methodical you're
like stupid AI you know this is the
reason we can't let the machines think
because if Mario Kart is an indication
to anything that the machines will
destroy us cuz they're mean but in 150cc
it is hard but it's really fun I mean
everyone's just neck-and-neck toe-to-toe
fighting everybody to get into first
place although a couple times they
totally dict out I got hit by a spike
shell while getting hit with a red shell
while getting hit by lightning while
people are just hitting me as they're
passing me because they're douches and
by people I mean the computer the
biggest dicks ever put on wheels more
than that too
Excel looking bastard and t2 telling you
don't let him think ever not for
themselves teachers coming however a
150cc is beatable and it's a lot of fun
man that's where the game is at your
heart's racing the entire time sometimes
you're in eighth place and you'll get
into first place then fourth place then
first place again it's fun you don't
feel like it's a complete inevitable
stomp that you just don't have legs
you're like yeah no it's just too cheap
like you know in video games the
computer will confine you to rules but
then they'll play by their own rules
like in Street Fighter you're fighting
Kyle and then he'll do sonic boom while
walking forward I like sonic boom boom
no you can't do that you have to hold
back while doing sonic boom you can't
walk forward and do it did ya against
the rules of reality Mario Kart 7 is not
like that it seems like they play on the
rules that everyone else plays on not
commonplace for you not commonplace for
them and 150 CCS where you start
unlocking characters to in 15 100cc I
was like wow just eight characters
that's all you get no 150cc you start
unlocking people so you're like okay
that's cool also you get to race with
your me when you beat I believe it's
fifty CC that's right you get you're me
now and I am mildly narcissistic enough
to where I'll be like yeah I'll rather
race as my me than the fat Italian
bastard who's mean and evil then there's
battle mode also battle mode I like but
not as much as some of the other ones
like in battle mode in Mario Kart that I
remember everyone has three balloons if
someone gets hit three times they're out
of battle mode now this one you have
three balloons but it doesn't really
matter ultimately you have unlimited
lives you have three balloons but you
can get hit fifty times it just means
someone probably scored a lot of points
against you and they're actually winning
and you have like two minutes to do it
though it's not a lot of time like I
like battle modes where it's like yeah I
can only get hit three times but the
matches last like 10 minutes that's
Mario Kart that I remember right there
my brother and I man we would go at it
we knew all the camp spots with the red
shells he was pretty patient it sucked
however they did away with that stupid
DS [ __ ] where you got to blow into the
screen to blow your balloon back up you
know you pass out because of it you're
all like well it got hit again
mmm yeah that was crap I didn't like
that this one has no gimmicks like that
that's what I like about 3d there are no
real gimmicks other than the 3d and the
3d in this game looks really good but
the 150 CC races are so intense and so
fast and just so high-octane you're like
yes this was worth the purchase price
right here this is it especially if you
have friends because it's fun racing
with friends dude seriously settle all
your problems right there and probably
get 5 more so what is your favorite
Mario Kart game they're different enough
swear I think that's actually a valid
question whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]